THURSDAY MARCH SEVENTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND. TWENTY TWO IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER AND OF COURSE I
HAVE TO NOTE THAT HERE WE ARE IN
THIS BEAUTIFUL NEW HEARING ROOM.
WHICH REPRESENTS. OBJECTIVE
PROOF THAT THE ANNEX PROJECT
WHICH HAS BEEN GRINDING AWAY.
LITERALLY FOR YEARS IS
UNFOLDING. AS WE CONVENE THIS
HEARING ROOM THE SENATE WILL
MEET IN THEIR HAIR ROOMS IN THIS
BUILDING. LATER TODAY. AND SO
THE EFFORT TO REMOVE ASBESTOS
AND OTHER. THINGS IN THE OLD
ANNEX WILL GET UNDERWAY. A
SERIOUS WAY WAS QUITE A
MILESTONE MORNING SO I JUST WANT
TO WELCOME YOU ALL. HERE AND- I
WAS HE WAS GOING ON THIS
BUILDING IS EACH HOUSE. LOST ONE
OR MORE HEARING ROOMS AND THEY
ACQUIRED A HEARING ROOM FOR THE
ONE THEY LOST AND- FOR THE
SENATE ACTUALLY LOST THREE
HEARING ROOMS WHERE WE LOST.
THIS FORTY TWO A TO SELL. ANYWAY
I JUST WANT TO WELCOME YOU HERE
OUR- ADVICE HERE WOULD YOU CARE
TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS ON THIS
OCCASION BEFORE WE REALLY GET
ROLLING. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRED ADDED JUST WANNA ECHO
YOUR COMMENTS AND THAT IT'S- AN
HONOR FOR US TO BE BREAKING IN
THIS ROOM. AS RULES COMMITTEE
AND THE- I GUESS THAT'S A KIND
OF APPROPRIATE ANYWAYS AND-
EXCITING TO BE IN THE NEW
BUILDING AND ACTUALLY NOT HAVING
TO RUN ACROSS THE STREET TO DO
OUR MEANING SO. L. I WILL KNOW
THAT MARIE BECAME MINORITY
LEADER IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WHICH MEANS WHEN SHE
BECAME MINORITY LEADER
REPUBLICAN LEADER. IN OUR HOUSE-
THIS BUILDING WAS STILL A
PARKING LOT. SO WE'VE HAD A LOT
OF DRAMATIC CHANGE- BRING HER
TENURE IN LEADERSHIP AND
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE ASSEMBLY
SO. VERY GOOD I'M- SO GOOD
MORNING THE RULES COMMITTEE AS I
SAY IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER.
VISION OP ADVICE OF AN AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEED IS BEING MADE. THERE'S
ALSO BEEN TELEVISED. ON MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING THIS
HEARING A REQUIRED ENCOURAGE
WERE MASK AT ALL TIMES.
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISTURBS THE SHRUBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
VIOLATION OF THE RULES MAY
SUBJECT INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR
OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS ON.
MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. COOLEY HERE WALDRON SENATE
HERE LARA IF. HERE GIPSON LOUIS
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RUBIO IPURUA
WE HAVE A QUORUM. WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
IS OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA. WE WERE MISERABL WOOD
WAS SECONDED BY. MR MATHIS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A MISTER SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY I
REALLY AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
BENNETT HI THEN IT HI FLORA FONG
HI FONG AYE GIPSON LEE I WE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE RUBIO HI
RUBIO IV APPROVED LAW. THE
VALLAPUDUA HIGH MOTION PASSES.
THAT MOTIONS PASSED I THANK YOU
ALL I'M GOING TO REMAIN A MALL
WE HAVE A MEMBER TO THE STUCK IN
TRAFFIC. THIS YEAR BUT I THANK
YOU ALL OF JOIN YOU ON THE FLOOR
SHORTLY. YEAH.
M. WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
GIPSON. HI GIPSON HI. ALL RIGHT
OKAY OF THAT MEASURE HAS PASSED
THE MOST IS PASS AND THIS RULES
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.